It's better to be cautious and avoid contact with other people as much as possible.I
wonder if I'll be tracked using the eyewitness testimony of local
people.Mirror SugimotoTourette and
others.
I'm going to these guys.
I'm digging something.I wonder if
they're looking for insects
.
Your brain is delicious
[music]
Hey, you should stop it coen, right?
We know the traps that make use of the woodcock's habits We made a passage with branches that the woodcock wants to pass through.
It might not be
there, so I'm going to show him the ruts until the next
time.
This
guy, who's mad, was told by his father that he couldn't do it, so he got mad.